there may be a path to peace between the
Israelis and the
Palestinians the Saudi normalization
deal an agreement between Israel and
Saudi Arabia to establish formal
diplomatic relations in return for a set
of terms including Israel's recognition
of a Palestinian
state in public Benyamin Netanyahu has
scorned America's attempts at a peace
deal I security and the prospects of
Peace in the Middle East depend on one
thing total victory over Hamas but in
private he said to be more
flexible so How likely is it the deal
will
succeed the Saudis have been talking
about normalization with Israel for
years this is something that predates uh
October 7th it's something that they
have been thinking about since Joe Biden
took office and and they've been
building a quiet relationship with
Israel for a decade or more uh
cultivating military ties intelligence
and security ties with Israel prime
minister netan has visited Saudi Arabia
more than once even though Israel and
Saudi Arabia don't have official
diplomatic relations it probably helps
to think of it as a set of nested boxes
in which if you want to solve the more
than Century old Israeli Palestinian
conflict you need a two-state solution
the key to the two-state solution is the
Saudi normalization deal because that is
what makes it more palatable to Israelis
the key to the Saudi normalization deal
is ending the war in Gaza because no
Arab State can actually move on this
front until the fighting ends the key to
ending the war in Gaza is the hostage
agreement because Israel will not stop
at least until it gets the hostages back
then you have the bigger problem of how
do you lock this into the Saudi
normalization deal and there the
Americans are going to have to put in a
fair amount of their own currency the
Saudis are demanding a defense treaty a
formal defense treaty with the United
States and they also want access to
nuclear technology a civilian nuclear
program but as Iran shows once you get
nuclear capability you are closer to
being able to develop a nuclear bomb so
there will be a lot of caution about
this both these things are quite
difficult for the United States to
concede but for the sake of that
historic deal it seems that President
Biden is willing to do it Anton you've
been talking to the people negotiating
this deal uh over the past few days tell
us a bit what the mood is like well I
think desperate to wind down the war is
certainly true officials are giving it a
a 50-50 chance and then once they lock
that in they think there's another 50/50
chance of getting the wider
normalization deal the odds are the S
normalization deal doesn't happen but
they're probably bigger than anybody
would have given it and I think it comes
from the realization that something has
to happen and I think they feel this
moment when Israel is struggling to
achieve its War aims and is seeing the
contradiction between destroying Hamas
and getting the hostages back may be the
right moment to push for
Progress thanks for watching to watch
our experts full discussion click the
link and subscribe to The
Economist